hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde sieht derzeit ganz danach aus
dass online unterricht bald wieder für
viele schüler zur tagesordnung gehört
von daher dachte ich mir schauen wir uns
heute mal einige online swing fällig
hier sollte jemand in einem chemie
onlinespiel sein experiment vorstellen
konstant gewachsen
ja das ist wirklich super geklappt was
auch super geklappt hat ist dass die
antworten verein test von der
lehrerinnen geheim gehalten werden hier
im nächsten zoomen kein schüler die
antworten für den test an die anderen
schüler zum schicken prozent so eine
richtige carron factor haben
und petzners an die lehrerin warum
zurück
der mathelehrer fragt nachdem er das
hier den schülern erklärt hatten nun ob
jemand eine frage hat und ein schüler
hat eine frage
er hat allerdings aus versehen noch so
ein sound filter aktiviert
[Musik]
wie sich hier einige leute mit technik
auskennen und das ist auch beim nächsten
fall der fall denn der lehrer kennt sich
hier nicht mit der zoom rekord funktion
aus und denkt der call ist schon vorbei
ist aber nicht einfach mal die komplette
klasse nachher dessen bei dem kollegen
ich schwöre genauso läuft wahrscheinlich
auch im lehrerzimmer abnahm unterrichts
klassenlehrer bestimmt stolz auf die
nächsten online school fell beleidigt
ein schüler eine andere schülerin und
sagt einfach herr du siehst heute echt
schlecht aus in denen karina und dann
schaltet sich die lehrerin ein und gibt
ihm einfach nach hilfe
ja
hj
er muss jetzt einfach nach der online
school doch länger im kopf drin bleiben
weil der nachsitzen muss beim nächsten
online fail hatten schüler wieder eine
frage an die lehrerin gehen alle so
respektvoll mit ihren lehrern um aber
manchmal gibt es wirklich auch
situationen wo man nicht mit lehrern
respektvoll umgehen sollte
beispiel wenn sie komplett keine ahnung
von technik haben wie im nächsten
beispiel
eine lehrerin ihre lautsprecher auf
sturm hat sie also nichts hört und
deswegen denkt kein schüler wäre
anwesend ist auch kein unterricht haben
mit einer lehrerin die nicht mal ihre
lautsprecher einschalten kann am ende
schreit einfach alle nur noch hier rum
nächsten ins boot felge zum zwei jungs
die immer andere sachen machen während
des recalls als er sich aufs lernen zu
konzentrieren
[Musik]
stark
was auch starkes ist dass sich hier ein
mädel vergessen hat zum newton und
einfach da mal während der online class
angefangen hat zu singen
ich glaube dass
die größte angst die man hat
vergisst sich auf new zu stellen es
umgekehrt ist natürlich auch blöd wenn
du die ganze zeit denkst du redest mit
einer person du bist aber doch auf mut
zum beispiel bayern morgen hast passiert
das relativ häufig der nächste online
school fate ist kein richtiger online
school feld sondern eine sache die ich
mich auch schon oft gefragt haben und
zwar kann man nicht einfach spicken weil
das denkt sich der dead von dem mädel
hier auch er regt sich ja einfach und
normal darüber auf dass seine tochter
nur 53 von 60 punkten hat weil sie
einfach einstecken können und ihn dort
sagt einfach ich hab doch gespickt was
ist das komisch oder
hier möchte eine junge im online
unterricht seine hausaufgaben
präsentieren und dafür seinen bildschirm
teilen
dafür muss man allerdings horst sein
also der macher der gruppe b ghana rp
online und direkt auf jeden fall stufte
ihn seine lehrerinnen dann hoch als host
und er nutzt das dann aus
[Musik]
und das krasse ist der gleiche typ hat
ein paar wochen später etwas sehr
ähnliches mit der gleichen lehrerin
wieder gemacht also hier haben wir wie
bereits gesagt die gleiche person wie
beim vorigen online school fell und in
seinem unterricht wird eine frage
gestellt von einer mitschülerin von ihm
und er meint er kann die frage
beantworten dafür musste allerdings
natürlich wieder seinen screentime die
lehrerin bezieht sich ebenfalls auf die
letzte situation und sagt hey das letzte
mal als ich die rechte gegeben habe
damit du uns einen screen zeigen kannst
ist mein internet gecrasht dann scheint
nicht mal gecheckt dass sie damals
rausgekickt wurde
er bekommt also nochmal eine chance von
der gleichen lehrerin um seinen screen
zu zeigen
und jetzt schaut mal was er macht
dann auf jeden fall die schülerin die
ihre fragen beantwortet haben wollte
noch mal alle meinte das war gar nicht
die lösung für meine frage das war gar
nicht die antwort und er ist ja host und
mutet sie dann einfach
[Musik]
es gibt so geisteskrank witzige leute
mit lustigen ideen aufsuchen genauso wie
der nächste
ich fürchte gibt einfach mal komplett ja
wirklich eine super schauspieler gruppe
die da stand von einem seiner
lieblingsfilme und nächsten fell sagt
eine lehrerin ihren schülern hey wenn
ihr heute mit dabei war bekommt ihr 100
punkte im great buch also klassenbuch
keine ahnung auf jeden fall sagte eine
mitschülerin dann einfach in ihren satz
rein hey du siehst echt heiß auf youtube
von der lehrerin menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend aber es gibt wirklich
auch und damit wenn ich das heutige
video auf beenden sehr schöne momente
die in online school in sachen
stattfinden von daher leute falls online
screen wiederkommen sollte freut euch
drauf ihr müsst euch nicht mehr in
dieser extrem kalten durchlüfteten
klassenräume setzen und es kann noch so
schön situationen kommen wie
beispielsweise beim nächsten so schaut
euch das an lasten daumen hoch beim
video da abonniert main kanal falls noch
kein teil von luxus
[Musik]
sieht man das